- If you follow me on Instagram,
welcome to the party and thank you.
You know that I love to
share tips and tricks
to all things from design to beauty.
And I actually posted a video using Crest,
which I just posted 'cause I love it,
and I've been using it my whole life
and it whitens my teeth and I'm a diehard.
So Crest saw the video
and reached out to see
if we could team up.
And I thought, ah yes, please count me in.
So we're gonna celebrate what they say
is their strongest
whitening toothpaste yet.
Ah Crest 3D White Brilliance.
(clapping)
I'm so excited.
Well they're making people smile,
so let me introduce you to
someone who's really going
to put a smile on your
face like she did to mine.
She's a brilliant young
woman doing brilliant things.
At just 17 years old,
she's the innovator behind Talking Masks,
which are specifically designed for those
who need to read lips.
Please welcome 17 year
old Isabella Appell.
(audience cheering)
Hi Isabella.
- Hi Drew.
- Hello.
- I'm so excited to be here today.
- I am so glad that we've
been brought together.
I love your story so much and
I'm gonna start by saying,
obviously masks are a reality
of the world right now,
and you wanted to take
a different approach.
Will you please tell
me about what you did?
- Yes so I created Talking Masks
at the beginning of quarantine,
which my goal with that
was to raise awareness
for the deaf and hard of hearing
community during this time.
And with this Talking
Mask, as you can see,
it has a clear window on it,
which allows for those
who rely on lip reading
to communicate, do so.
- And you don't profit off of this do you?
- No I make no profit at all.
Every donation goes directly
to the Hearing Aid Project,
which provides hearing aids to those
who cannot afford them themselves.
- Well.
(audience clapping)
I know we all love you here so much.
I also heard on top of being a pioneer
and a businesswoman and
an all around do-gooder,
you just became president of your school.
- Yes I did, last week.
- Okay what's your
first order of business?
- Okay well obviously during this time,
bringing together my school as a community
is so important to me.
So my goal with that is to
invite one board representative
from every club on campus
to student council,
and that way we can help them with events,
maybe hang posters for them,
or just get more people involved
in their club in general.
- Do you like to have a nice,
like well rounded out group
that represents different needs,
viewpoints, interests so
that you can really diversify
for your school?
- Yeah that's one of the main goals of my,
of me being in student
council this year actually.
- That's what I was getting the sense of.
I just,
I admire that so much.
I just think when we can come together,
I'm so in favor of that,
and we're so impressed with you here.
We're in awe of all the
things you're accomplishing
and we're gonna be donating $5,000
to the Hearing Aid Project of yours.
And Target is going to give you
a $1,000 gift card for supplies.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- Actually thank you Isabella,
and we can't wait to watch you
take over the world one
bright smile at a time.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Isabella.
And when Crest teamed up with us,
they actually told our whole
team that they truly believe
in their product because they want people
to have confidence to
unleash their own smile.
That's actually seriously a term that they
and their team uses.
Ready?
Unleash your smile.
And if Crest 3D White
Brilliance can encourage you
to have a little more
confidence on your next Zoom,
well that's what they did for me.
So I think we can all smile together now.
Thanks to Crest.
(upbeat music)